strain my day jockey block my night all
day when Claudia is by far the best 150
pound girl in the world not named Yelena
she's so [ __ ] good she's pretty
bodied up she's very much crashing up he
should take a little Brazilian pitbull
and it was cute when that those six-pack
son that says I'm all she's gained her
she wants to do Evi to repenting
depending on how this fight ends she
comes out anytime nice and world
champion yeah she's she's an athlete
she's gangster Oh Mario the hearts doing
that hard thing because uh he really
loves emojis but he can't bring one into
the office on with him look at body
Italia relaxed as [ __ ] that's Karolina
key Balkan whatever her name is
I meant that to my men he's my
girlfriend Claudia today I know I know
that I just love I love Poland I love
her I think she's gorgeous
they're both soo gonna be is what she is
and let's see if she gets the rub right
she went five hard rounds but you wanna
let's see what what comes back
oh the lean right hand she lands the
polls have been through the worst their
history and I [ __ ] up octagon I went to
World War one and to [ __ ] she's
into you then we [ __ ] around eating
munitions their breakfast they suck hole
hero playing in both forces I saw one
bite ins nothing
you saw Wonder Woman are what it's like
our girl patty Jenkins by the way number
one I think it's gonna be the biggest
growth 94 on for a woman I'm proud of
her I love a good [ __ ] movie I heard
it's really good it's good yes I see if
you like superhero movies and I love
superhero movie I'm it's a good [ __ ]
superhero tell yes look when you make a
superhero movie you're confined by
having to make a movie about a superhero
and the good guys to win and you know
that going in she dealt with all that
and she did it she did it on our own
term it's not about man or wood it's not
a hero
it's about patty pumpkins the dude I
want to spoil or I almost Burrell don't
land on wonder what wonder woman argue
that patty Jenkins really love enjoyed
the [ __ ] traded are you know what I
hear is good come on iTunes now is that
move your life that Ryan Reynolds movie
people keep telling me they'll really do
that movie husband dope Chris Pine is
hilarious and Wonder Woman though right
I love that guy you don't know today I
get a bad father of the Year work when I
let my nine-year-old watch the original
alien
[ __ ] Oh milk so she goes TVs is okay I
think she's okay so she's like it's not
real daddy if it was a real thing I'd be
scared of it but I'm not scared to it
pointed I love it
kids man they have iPads they get online
when you're not looking I can see all
kinds of [ __ ] and avatar [ __ ] things up
if you know a [ __ ] mix of that they know
things my turret might add or use the
word the name [ __ ] today and I had to
scold her oh you should look at that
guy's an [ __ ] I was like hey she said
you right but don't tell anybody right
okay but the thing about the alien movie
is that there's no CGI it's all like a
mama can't help it but now it's a dude
in a suit so it looks real as [ __ ] that
movie was done so well Rick Lee Scott
was a wizard yes he is they did
everything in the dark everything was
like real sneaky you only saw the alien
for like quick bursts of snow it's just
like American Werewolf in London with
John Landon you see it like oh look like
under - trouble no side control did you
see the new alien I did not see oh you
got us I know I do
anyone is so damodar's I'm getting
people to go no one in my household is
capable and my wife said I could let her
watch the original alien on TV but I
can't take her to the movies to see the
new alien so yeah wait there comes on
dear demand [ __ ] the wife rules you make
the road [ __ ] yeah
now [ __ ] private we were trying to
keep keep us all the time so we were
trying to keep it too
we didn't want to you know we don't
farted my wife [ __ ] was a bet so we're
trying to keep it - don't - oh yeah
dammit whoo that was a big mistake
that's a huge huge victory for her oh my
god
obviously is that powerful New Mexico in
the house here's this here's the
question Joe jeepers those two three I
guess you wanna yeah Roza supposed to be
next up well [ __ ] that was a crazy she
looked not good I'm gonna go MMA
mathematic Karolina Karolina just got
murked just super Burt I go it was to
relax I got my rounds of young it
doesn't matter if you're relaxed or if
you look nervous
all that matters is how your ground game
how does that happen so you just like
pretending that everything's cool
leaning against the fence diving in a
that's like education shows red robe and
she's just okay what was the mistake she
made there well you don't want to learn
yet little Claude yes first of all it's
physically a beast you're in the first
round
no one's tired yesterday the one turns
away oh my god towards her she gave her
back up and we're second grader bully
you got your boy sure it is man it's
panic [ __ ] you just like I want muscle
my way back up to my feet but now she's
a guy not under the jacket world all
ended right yeah
she's controlling here right yeah she's
got her and she's also if you serious
she's only got one let's go one go two
on one she's fine oh sorry Allan and
then look at that second hook one side
under the chin then she goes second hook
I could dance so shunt wait oh yeah
that's an undeniable choke right there
that's like you're going to sleep yeah
once especially he deserves the title
shuttle I think she does I really won
see Rose Cardenas sorry rose that's it
is we gotta go with updating of Brazil
yeah dude if anything my girlfriend some
citrus rookie I would like to see her
versus Rose let's get this started yeah
you want to wash it up I would say all
my foot hurt me too I put her enemy
online and you can't go I need to take
their pee this short me and Amanda me
can everyone ran directly went I'm good
I'll just [ __ ] your belt your enemies
like yeah I never really wanted to fight
145 in the first place going on 35 and
that
arms to us via her name John Jack Jack
young John I got close yeah little by
little your honor you're mine we got it
after two years I would say 80% of MMA
fans know how to say her name now that's
a cheetah another I say he still calls
her champion Brian Stann cousin you want
to champion this news can't pronounce
became another friend one more turn
Youngjae check your not check your jail
like you know why you liked young Jamie
no no no like why you went they spell it
out from your netic Allah when I have to
read it for the n ginger when I am done
reinitiate I might be doing it wrong but
when I have to read it for the Wayans
it's like why un j ay Y and then check
it was your first what is your last name
start with what's the first day JJ okay
like JJ easy should just change JJ's
gonna just say sp
come on change is like close that was a
caller I know mostly guns on a bad idea
though she's only JJ other than John
Jones there's one too much confusion but
the problem on your Jess you know like
jy that's like one of them them taught
what once the Thai guys start flooding
in the MMA oh you thought you had it
hard with the Polish people you know hi
guys come in they got like 25 letters
and I gotta see for quite some bling
well Wow
[Applause]
[Music]